ja und jetzt sind wir die eltern der
beiden der isabella fritz und christian
leicher wir sehen auch isabella die
wichtigste frage an sie wie geht es
ihnen heute und vor allem auch wie geht
es die tabelle heute ist er bella bella
geht es gut wir uns nicht so gut weil
bei uns läuft die zeit langsam davon
wir müssen wieder arbeiten ich meine
frau wird unser geld weg ist es war ja
eben beitrag schon angeschnitten aber
wir können nicht arbeiten weil es ist
niemand für isabella da wir haben keinen
pfleger und stehen eigentlich pfleger zu
es wird viel geld dafür bereitgestellt
aber in den gronauer zeiten ist einfach
kein pfleger verfügbar ist war vorher
schon schwierig und jetzt meldet sich
überhaupt keinen wir arbeiten tag und
nacht mit der isabella wir warten ihre
geräte
wir sorgen dafür dass sie immer genug
sauerstoff bekommt wir verhindern
notfälle und wenn notfälle austreten
begeben wir diese aber wir werden als
pfleger nicht anerkannte probleme das
jahrelang schon erfolgreich machen sei
es bei uns keinen pfennig geld und lässt
uns einfach einfach im regen stehen
was macht ihr denn eigentlich dann doch
nicht so gut was haben sie denn alles
schon getan um hilfe zu bekommen und es
geht ja auch vor allem um die impfung
dass sie eben ihre tochter schützen
können wo haben sich dann schon überall
hin gewandt wir haben uns irgendwie
kinderkliniken gewarnt ich habe mich ans
lka gewandt ich habe mich ans paul
ehrlich institut gewarnt ich habe mich
hier in münchen an die klinikum rechts
der isar gewarnt dann die im virologie
keiner kann uns helfen
jeder glaubt uns einfach ab sie sind
nicht dafür zuständig sie haben ja
gerade schon angesprochen dass sie ihre
tochter 24 stunden betreuen müssen die
müssen sie pflegen und eigentlich ist
die im priorität ja so dass ältere
menschen zuerst geimpft werden aber eben
auch medizinisches personal
haben sie dafür verständnis dass sie
trotzdem nicht so schnell dran sind
ich habe da überhaupt kein verständnis
dafür weil kinder risiko kennen das in
der völlig ausgegrenzt in dieser
verordnung
sie werden mit keinem wort erwähnt da
kommen vorher der dickleibigen hatte ich
ja schon mal gesagt und die
einzelhändler dran vor wir an
daran kommen am besten wäre es wenn man
uns als pflegekräfte anerkannt würde uns
geld zahlen würde damit wir vernünftig
leben können und die isabella nicht
allein lassen müssen
und mit dieser anerkennung wie das
automatisch dann so dass wir auch nimmt
was uns auch eine impfung zustehen würde
das war unser ziel danke schön dass sie
sich die zeit genommen haben wir hoffen
natürlich dass er hilferufe gehört wird
und dass sie dann letztendlich doch
früher dran sind und früher geimpft
werden können alles alles gute und
bleibende noch einen hilferuf an den
herren schröder an den hans oder
loswerden
mit der person helfen sie uns die haben
jetzt den 80 jährigen geholfen
bitte helfen sie auch der isabella sie
ist so süß ist wie sie dort doch die
gleiche priorität haben wir 80 jährige
es kann nicht sein dass man nur die
alten dem moment ich sehe es ein die
sind sehr wichtig dass man die nur
priorisiert bitte projizierten sie auch
isabella sie braucht dringend einen
impfstoff sie und ihr bruder da ihr
bruder kann seit einem jahr nicht mehr
in die schule gehen
er braucht auch den impfstoff nämlich
wenn er in die schule geht geht genau
dorthin wo ein fünftel der bevölkerung
nämlich alle minderjährigen nicht
geimpft sind
bitte bitte sorgen sie dafür dass ein
impfstoff für isabella zur verfügung
gestellt wird wir würden auch off label
impfen lassen wenn er für sie nicht
zugelassen ist
aber wir wollen die möglichkeit den
impfstoff zu bekommen
das sind völlig am ende vielen dank es
ist völlig ausgeschlossen von dieser
ganzen regulierung es also unter also
minderjährige werden überhaupt nicht
nirgends erwähnt es gibt natürlich
sowohl kinder die auch
hochrisikopatienten sind und sehr krank
sind obwohl sie nicht volljährig sind
und dass es isabella isabella stirbt
wenn sie angesteckt wird
man hört ihre verzweiflung wirklich raus
wir hoffen dass dieser hilferuf wirklich
bei markus söder kommt und dass ihnen
schnell geholfen wird vielen dank und
noch einen schönen abend wie ich zittere
man sieht das vielleicht ich zittere
einfach
alles gute passende auch sie auf und
bleiben sie gesund ja wir brauchen
wirklich dringend hilfe wie auch immer
uns helfen kann
dankeschön